where did you with her okay Hey here we
are yeah we got the mail out back there
with the shirt sold all day made the
shirts today the shirts look good yeah
real good
and pookie decided that she's gonna try
and swim through all the pile of
envelopes here oh sure okay but you have
to put them you could have worn the one
that we made for you is in here you know
wow this is like really lagging it's
even lagging on my thing yeah yeah who's
Janice can we see it can we see it yeah
there it is yeah super cool all right
yeah let me see if I can get it up
closer to the camera yeah cookies trying
to swim in the whole [ __ ] mail out
also I'm not sure which shirt it was so
this is fun but um Pookie licked one of
them yeah when I was like I had the pile
of shirt and I had the pile of envelopes
and then I looked up when I was getting
the next one to fold and she was licking
it like okay we got this huge mail all
the envelopes ready yeah cookies back
there trying to swim through all the
envelopes yeah she's very excited and
she was very excited that I had the
t-shirt box open as well she was jumping
in and out of it like Jackie Chan this
was Justin's yeah just yeah put them
back what are you doing oh now she's
laying on her back just next all the in
the mail okay so he wants to mail
herself somewhere I guess yeah um got
the first design printed out yeah yes we
got to do that tomorrow but then we're
gonna mail them we're gonna do I think I
only have three more to print and then
we'll smell them tomorrow problems okay
um so yeah before we get started talking
about the movie um this is like really
look it's like really lagging on mine
today to you that's really weird I've
never had that happen before I mention
it live it's lagging maybe I should well
yeah it's like but normally it's not
lagging like on my laptop but today it
is so it's like I'm gonna try not to
look at it comment oh thank you Matt
thank you thank you thank you thank you
very much man yeah Pookie lecture is
worth
fortune that's what I said it's like I
don't know which one it was like an hour
wood size when it was that because I
just looked up and saw her licking it
and I was like okay fair enough
I was like so it's like Pookie licking
the Pookie licking lottery so when one
of you is getting a shirt with Pookie
lick on it alright so before we get
started talking about the movie shout
out who wanted to give you another shout
out - yeah yes sounds of movies all the
time so send us like one package I think
it was yesterday right yeah had like
Ghostbusters or Ghostbusters one and two
one and two didn't have that one which
is awesome look it comes in like a book
and stuff isn't that rad and then I was
in there watching predators because
Oliver Harper [ __ ] did a review on
predators yesterday oh yeah I want to
see that one so I was watching it and
what came in the mail is another one
from from mr. Hernandez right and it's
all of them all the predator predator
once and I have them all already but I
don't know how to say you don't have
that and two things are gonna happen
one that will condense the you know free
up more room yeah and predator one okay
I have the ultimate hunter Edition which
some people say isn't a great transfer
it could be that the predator now on
that's a better blu-ray transfer yeah
that would be ray isn't it yeah so so
that's probably all the updated
transfers and extras and [ __ ] so man
thank you very much thank you all right
so uh movie we're gonna talk about today
this was a nice little surprise wasn't
it yes good movie
this actually just dropped on shudder
she's probably like a week ago I think I
noticed it I guess what ended up
happening with this like from what I
could determine was that I think it
premiered at fantastic in November of
2019 I believe and then like it didn't
it didn't look like it was gonna get a
distributor even though it got like
really good reviews and seemed to be
like a crowd-pleaser at the festival but
it so happened that shudder actually
picked it up and we got to see it and
like I said I just picked it because it
was new it's actually a Thai film
yeah and it's called the pool yeah and
it's
anteye yeah it doesn't matter because
there's not a lot of dialogue in it and
it the sort of story is very simple dude
damn [ __ ] ends up getting stranded in
about 30 foot pool and there's no way
out and there's damn alligator in there
with him it's a crocodile crocodile yeah
call it [ __ ] alligator and the alligator
doesn't look real but it doesn't matter
it's real enough and so much cool [ __ ]
happens in the movie him trying to
survive and I can't spoil it but this
movie [ __ ] had you [ __ ] rooting
for the guy it's almost full flick
that's it's it kind of like reminding
because remember that one we saw the Sam
Raimi produce one crawl yeah that was
just like you know it's almost the same
setup is that in the sense that it's
it's kind of like very a very simple
concept it's one location yeah and it
doesn't have like I said the only you
know the only thing that I would say in
you know in the negative column was yes
in some shots the crocodile liked the
CGI doesn't look all that real yeah but
it yeah it's like it's really not all
that bad it really doesn't look real
only in parts where like it's kind of
like close up with some we're like
attacking somebody I feel like they
might have used a real crocodile for the
far off shots because the far off ones
like where they just had it walking or
whatever that looked like a real
crocodile but the close-up ones not so
it's still really good CGI it's just
wasn't like perfectly you know so I'm
like just nitpicking but the best thing
about it okay so the thing is that
there's a guy named a and he is I guess
he's like some low-level like he works
on a film set or something I think what
they're shooting at the beginning is a
commercial right as commercial and it
was gonna be an underwater shot of this
girl dressed up like a damn clown in a
[ __ ] gown underneath the water
swimming around laying on a couch it had
Deb couch underneath there and
everything in the pool they made him go
down there and [ __ ] do things with
lighting I think it was yeah I think he
was a lighting guy right so they were
shooting this commercial and he had the
dog he his dog Lucky was like he was the
dog Wrangler as well
yeah and so I guess what ended up
happening was that after the commercial
shoot were shooting
it looked like a you know SportsCenter
or something so it was like an Olympic
sized pool it's a really big really deep
pool with like a bunch of those like
high diving board yeah they didn't have
a it didn't have a a low section the
whole thing yeah it was just all deep
and and there's no ladder in or out of
it and after the after the shooting he
was [ __ ] around on a damn rubber raft
floating around out and they're getting
ready to get off work and he was waiting
on something with his girlfriend and
somebody [ __ ] opened the pool and
drained it he fell asleep and it drained
all of that water yeah because he knew
that it was getting drained because his
friend was like oh I'm gonna like put
the drain on the pool over like you know
just clean up everything after you leave
yeah and I guess he was just like yeah
whatever and he just fell asleep so he
didn't realize how much time had gone by
so by the time he woke up there was
still a lot of water in the pool but it
was too late he couldn't reach the edge
and get out couldn't reach and pull
himself up man it's and one thing leads
to another and then it's like about an
hour and a half of this [ __ ] crazy
ass [ __ ] survival adventure slash
horror of him trying to get out his damn
pool and the dogs there and an
alligator's there I just there's a lot
of [ __ ] bad [ __ ] happens and this
girlfriend is there yeah I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna spoil that happening and
shit's frustrating as [ __ ] and just you
know every time you think maybe he's got
away again that it's like no and then he
gets I'm not gonna [ __ ] father that
man second the best thing about this
movie is that it just kept I cuz I told
him we were joking about it um I said I
told him I said this should be called
[ __ ] my life in a movie because it just
seems like every time like it seemed
like it couldn't get worse like it just
kept getting worse and worse and worse
and it just kept like turn and the
screws and turning the screws like to
the point where it was you know I'm
gonna use the word it was ridiculous but
not in a bad way like in a rather
awesome way where you were just like oh
no and like a couple times like when a
couple say
happened I wasn't even drinking or
anything but a couple times when
something happened in it I was just like
Oh like oh [ __ ] that poor guy so it was
just kind of like that you really
believe felt for the dude because it was
just so yeah frustrating I mean I think
you even like jumped up off the bed one
time I was like [ __ ] this movie yeah
it's almost kind of it's almost weird so
most kind of like a Twilight Zone
episode and what I did like about the
movie is that there wasn't any kind of
[ __ ] hokey messaging in it or
anything like that it's just kind of old
school movie and with a [ __ ] blatant
product [ __ ] placement from Pizza Hut
at the very beginning
brought to you by Pizza Hut and then
they get the Pizza Hut [ __ ] out of
the way plug I'll tell you what it
wasn't as because I'm gonna say like as
soon as the movie came on like you know
where it has like all the production
company logos it had like the Pizza Hut
he says logo like next to one of the
production company things so I said oh
this is gonna be like a big long pizza
commercial town a pizza so it actually
wasn't if they did have like obviously
like a little bit of a Pizza Hut they
were like a guy came to the pool to like
deliver a pizza that had been called for
yeah that was cool it figured into the
plot like later on so it wasn't like
completely egregious and that was the
only time they did it wasn't like
everybody was like pizza this pizza what
was funny is it was like it was
unabashedly a [ __ ] Pizza Hut plug and
yeah looking the tone was perfect it was
like here comes the pizza hey Pizza
laughs you know I was going like well
the thing is like if a corporation is
gonna pay for part of your movie which
I'm assuming the pizza did in this since
their logos in the beginning yeah that
seems to be the best way to go about it
because they were trying to buy a gun
being sneaky you know they made a little
bit of a gag about it it did actually
factor into the plot later on um you
know the pizza being there like the
pizza guy leaving it there like that did
actually matter to the plotter so it
wasn't just like and they didn't do it
through the whole movie it was just that
one time
so I dinner
it wasn't like a thing where was what
was that one horrible movie from the 80s
Mac and me that was a kiss shown the
pitiable Bush is pretty much a big long
McDonald's coverage as I said when I
cast the movie took place in [ __ ]
McDonald's it was like [ __ ] dancin and
McDonald's and out in front of
McDonald's et ripoff yeah it was like
it's awful but it's like really really
funny and I actually the the newer MST
did it I think they did it on the first
episode of the gauntlet and that was
like one of the fun yeah that was that
was a perfect plug if you got a you got
a plug it in the movie [ __ ] make it
enjoyable yeah that's the way to do it
didn't bother me at all I just thought
it was very funny but yeah it's like the
you know it didn't really have you know
there wasn't like a huge amount of
dialogue it was a huge amount of
backstory like pretty much the only
thing that was like a backstory
backstory was that you know he had a
girlfriend named coy and she was you
know pregnant or like you know he didn't
know she was pregnant like at first and
so it seemed like the whole movie was
kind of like him like accepting
fatherhood I guess too but they that was
kind of like kept to a minimum pretty
much and it just kind of like gave him
impetus to get out of this horrible
situation but I mean this is the way you
make a monster movie just in one
location for no money essentially two
characters and in a dog yeah and um I'm
gonna say right now if you get upset at
like dot at bad things happening to dogs
then well it's not that bad with a movie
the dog did the dog was the hero the dog
yeah so I'm just gonna say if that's
really gonna buy what it wasn't
unnecessary cruelty or anything he
wasn't like you know [ __ ] cannibals
yeah it wasn't like that wasn't like
that but it's obviously not a real dog
yeah but that was pretty much that this
is really the way you do it because you
cared about this guy you can
about his girlfriend you could imagine
being even though even as the situation
got more and more like oh my god like
[ __ ] really the universe hates this
guy because every time he it seemed like
he had some kind of triumph like
something like even worse what happened
and it was just like are mine so it
strains credulity but not in a bad way
like there was nothing that was just
like outlandish no I just kept topping
itself right if that's what this movie
was yeah it's it's not a dialogue driven
movie it's all [ __ ] physical adventure
so it has to yeah and it's taken it has
to do what it did is taking place just
in a dance woman pool yeah so how are
you gonna make that exciting well
they're gonna show you how they made
that exciting
yeah and Nathan of his [ __ ] did a
[ __ ] great job kind of reminded me of
something that would be like a Stephen
King short story like survivor type
remember that yeah kind of like
something like where that guy started
like or less violence or like you to
wrath self know like the raft where you
can't get off the damn [ __ ] raft
because the monster would get you yeah
I'm kind of like that yeah this was
basically like that it's just basically
almost the whole thing other than a
couple of flashbacks take place in the
bottom of a empty swimming pool yeah and
you know there's a crocodile there but
there's other I mean there other than
happening [ __ ] happening to it's not
just the crocodile um so this guy has to
like think of all these things like to
try to get this pool to try to keep from
getting eaten by the crocodiles it's
just one factor yes I think that's what
makes it good because every time you
know and he's not a dummy like he
actually like you know tries to do [ __ ]
tries to figure [ __ ] out yeah like to
get out like pretty much the whole time
he's like thinking is like maybe we can
do this maybe we can do that and it you
know just the fact that it keeps going
thank you thank you very much do you
think okay just the fact that everything
he does like either fails or make
something worse or something like that
and it's just so it made it like I want
to say frustrating but not pressuring in
a bad way it was like a really really
fun watch because it was almost funny
yeah you know what I mean just like
because I was just like oh oh you gotta
be [ __ ] me like now this is
happening but it was it was funny in
that way just for the ridiculousness
factor but it was
you know also you felt super bad for the
dude because you know we've we've all
had days like this where it just seemed
like nothing goes right and like it so
it seemed like that but like to the nth
power
yeah so you really could relate to the
dude and you felt really bad for him and
then like but you know by the end you
were just like when if he had like some
little triumph you were like yeah I mean
so it's like this was like a really
really well done you know I'm you know
horror thriller I guess I would call it
kind of a creature feature too because
of the crocodile even though there was
other [ __ ] going on as well
but you know just a really fun maybe I
can see why it got um you know a real
good response at Fantastic Fest I guess
like a lot of people saw it yeah I
haven't seen an American movie like this
in a long long time yeah it's like I
said it's similar to crawl but I think I
liked this better not better crawlers
the one about the damn alligators
underneath the damn house right yeah
like during the hurricane yeah this one
was a lot better just because it was a
lot tighter a lot more focused yeah um a
lot more willing to just kind of keep
ramping up keep air we just abuse in
like the main character like but in a
way that you felt really bad for him
and um you know so I think that that was
like really really effective like the
way they did that and I had a [ __ ]
blast watching it I mean yeah well it
wasn't just abuse though either maybe he
was having moments a triumphant [ __ ]
yeah I was into the occasion it was a
roller trying to do a [ __ ] heroic
[ __ ] you know trying to save himself and
save other people it's just gotta see
it's a good movie yeah it's really
really good I mean and I didn't Bango
badger was saying earlier that he's
gonna add this to add this to the
shutter list oh definitely yes I mean
and you know like I said shuttered us a
sponsor us we don't get paid by them
anything like that I pay for a
subscription like everybody else does
but really I mean it's a really good
service I mean it's really very well
curated and they have I like that they
have a lot of classics on there they
also have a lot of foreign [ __ ] that I
might not have even heard of or seen
like this one um you know cuz like I
said I I feel like this didn't even it's
the Netflix of horror it really is
and you know like I think the English
system that and the UK version of it has
gotten better I think they added a bunch
of stuff yeah because I heard that some
people were like pissed off that it
didn't have him they were a complainin
that you can yeah they didn't have
everything that we had but I think they
I think they got it up to speed now yeah
I mean they don't have like zillions of
movies I mean they don't have as many
movies as Netflix but the thing about it
is all the classes yeah I mean but they
the ones they do have they really do
seem to have like you know a crew that
is really good at like picking out the
best one so they have like a really good
combination of you know new [ __ ] old
[ __ ] you know and like cult classics and
stuff like that they always have like a
really good mix of all that kind of
stuff even if they don't have like
zillions of movies Karen Stein hit that
like please apparently the more likes
and comments and [ __ ] like that you get
higher up in the I think algorithms you
get so it's like but I always forget to
tell people to comment yeah we forget we
forget to plug everything I know well
we're doing the show well the thing is
yeah it's like we're just doing that and
it's like I don't really have anything
scripted ahead of time and also I have
so many things going on right and so
many projects that I could plug at any
one time because I'm always like working
on 50 things at one yeah but now yeah
I'm still yeah I'm working on how much
the streaming faceless villain part four
would you we could actually pretty much
in this one I think yeah but this is a
good one yeah this is real good when I
really really likes this one a lot like
I said it's it's only like 91 minutes
and it just keeps on yeah no no fat no
filler on it no nothing it's just
basically just right out the gate just
keeps keeps on [ __ ] with you the
whole yeah it's just
yeah no slow spots oh yeah and I was
just like yelling at the TV the whole
time like no no no you know what I mean
it was just like like a terrible but
yeah but yes if you have shudder I
really recommend this you might be able
to rent it somewhere else I'm not real
sure at my feet
exclusive nah I'm not real sure about
that but you know kept shudder then
definitely check it out because it is
really really worth watching a really
really good film and we will probably
live stream again on Saturday yeah
either side track or another movie we'll
see what we're going on Alex Trevor says
I wish I had a fifth of your energy
Jenny I don't really have a lot of
energy yeah is it yeah it's really
really good it's good I really recommend
it yeah yeah it's - it's real simple
it's just it's just [ __ ] [ __ ] I like
- yeah yeah yeah you don't have to like
think about it too much is good you
drink just alright so we'll talk to you
guys again soon
well like I said probably on Saturday so
thanks everybody for stopping by and
thanks everybody that contributed and I
will talk to you later yeah that's good